new this morning president biden will
lay out his american jobs plan in
pittsburgh today with a price tag
of about two trillion dollars over the
next eight years
ed o'keefe is at the white house ed mr
biden says he can pay for the plan
tell us what's in it yeah good morning
adriana this stretches from some of the
nation's most iconic
buildings and bridges to the way water
gets into your homes the idea here is to
pass
one of the most expensive government
spending plans ever on par with building
the interstate highway system
and the space program back in the
nineteen sixties the plan includes
things like six hundred twenty one
billion dollars to repair roads
bridges and airports with a goal of
modernizing twenty thousand miles of
highways and streets
and to build five hundred thousand
electric vehicle charging stations by
twenty thirty
there'd be a hundred eleven billion
dollars to replace lead pipes and ensure
access to clean drinking water
a hundred billion to build new schools
another one hundred billion to expand
access to high-speed internet
and a hundred billion more to update the
nation's electrical systems
the president would pay for all of this
by hiking corporate tax rates from 21 to
28 percent
and changing how multinational companies
are taxed now remember
congressional republicans oppose any
talk of tax increases
the white house says it's going to be
reaching out to both sides to try to get
them to talk about this
but with the likelihood of
bipartisanship slim this is a political
fight adriana that's going to dominate
washington through most of the summer
yes it is especially after the covert
relief plan with such a high price tag
was a big fight so
ed president biden also announced new
actions to stop violence against
asian americans what can you tell us
about that that's right all of this
coming in the wake of those
terrible attacks on asian americans
across the country among other things
it includes relaunching a white house
initiative on asian americans and
pacific islanders which promotes
inclusion and opportunity for the asian
american pacific islander
community there is a new justice
department program to address anti-asian
violence making it easier to track and
report crimes and adding new funding for
aapi survivors of violence
and sexual assault all of this coming
amid criticism from asian american
lawmakers who say the binding
administration
hasn't moved fast enough aggressively
enough to address the concerns of the
aapi community
ed thank you